nos dicen un conductor tiene 28 autos
cada auto tiene 4 llantas él tiene que
reemplazar todas las llantas de los
autos él tiene 22 llantas ahora estima
el número total de llantas que necesita
comprar pausa en el vídeo y traten de
estimar lo y la palabra clave aquí es
justamente estimar no es necesario
calcular con exactitud sino encontrar un
número aproximado de llantas que él
necesita comprar muy bien resolvamos
esto juntos y como mencioné la palabra
clave aquí es estimar y estimar es algo
que haremos durante toda la vida yo
probablemente lo hago una vez al día al
menos cuando estimamos queremos que los
números sean aproximadamente correctos
pero también queremos pensar en cómo
esas aproximaciones nos pueden ayudar a
que los cálculos sean más sencillos o
amigables si yo quisiera saber
exactamente cuántas llantas él tiene que
comprar diría que él tiene 28 autos y
que cada auto tiene 4 llantas por lo que
si queremos saber el número total de
llantas multiplicamos 28 por 4 luego nos
dicen que él
y reemplazar todas las llantas de los
autos y si él no tuviera alguna llanta
este sería el número de llantas que
necesita reemplazar pero nos dicen que
él tiene 22 llantas ahora por lo que si
queremos calcular el número exacto
diríamos 28 por 4 que son las llantas
que él tiene que reemplazar pero como ya
tiene 22 le restamos 22 y todo este
número es la cantidad de llantas que él
tiene que comprar este cálculo no es tan
sencillo de hacer especialmente si lo
hacen en una servilleta o si lo hacen
mentalmente pero justo por eso lo vamos
a estimar para estimar tenemos que
pensar en cuál sería un número más
amigable que 28 y bueno 28 es muy
cercano a 30 por lo que decimos que 28
se aproxima a 30 esta es una forma de
hacer que el 28 sea un poco más amigable
el 4 ya es bastante sencillo de trabajar
y el 22 sería más sencillo si en lugar
de ser 22 se aproximará a 20 así que 22
es aproximadamente igual esto es lo que
significa este signo de igual curveado
es aproximadamente igual a 20 todo esto
simplifica mucho los cálculos
podemos decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a él tiene
aproximadamente 30 autos y cada uno de
esos autos necesita 4 llantas con esto
sabemos el número total de llantas que
necesita reemplazar pero a esto le
restamos el número de llantas que ya
tiene por lo que en lugar de restar 22
restamos las que él tiene
aproximadamente que son 20 este cálculo
es mucho más fácil de hacer mentalmente
3 x 4 es 12 por lo que 30 por 4 es 120 y
a esto le restamos 20 120 menos 20 es
igual a 100 por lo que si yo fuera a
estimar el número total de llantas que
él necesita comprar serían 100 llantas